there is a kind of person who seems at
first glance to benefit from an
admirable degree of self-motivation
thoroughness and drive
they are up at dawn they rarely take
holidays they are always sneaking in an
extra hour or two of work
their bosses are highly impressed they
are constantly promoted their grades
have been excellent since primary school
they never miss an appointment or turn
in a piece of work that is less than
stellar
we like to say that such a person has
high standards we might even anoint them
with the term perfectionist
it might seem chillish to locate any
problems here why complain about a
somewhat overzealous devotion to
perfection in a troubled and
lackadaisical world
there could surely be nothing too awful
about high exactitude
what could be so imperfect about
perfectionism
the concern is not so much with the work
of the perfectionist its recipients are
in a very privileged position
as with the state of their soul
perfectionism does not tragically spring
first and foremost from any kind of love
of perfection in and of itself
it has its origins in a far more
regrettable feeling of never being good
enough
it is rooted in self-hatred sparked by
memories of being disapproved of or
neglected by those who should have more
fairly esteemed us warmly in childhood
we become perfectionists from a primary
sense of being unworthy
uninteresting flawed a disappointment a
letdown a nuisance
so powerful is this sense so appalling
is it in its pressure on our psyches we
are prepared to do more or less anything
to expunge it
working at all hours
carrying favor with authority
doing twice as much as the next person
these are the tools with which we seek
to cleanse our apparently shamefully
undeserving selves
one part of the mind promises the other
that the completion of the next
challenge will finally usher in peace
we can be very good at pretending that
our ambitions are sane
but our work has a sisyphean dimension
no sooner have we rolled our working
boulder up the hill then it will tumble
back down again
there is never going to be a point of
rest or a lasting feeling of completion
we are in truth ill rather than driven
we aren't interested in perfect work at
all
we are trying to escape from a feeling
of being awful people
and work simply happens to be the medium
through which we are striving to grow
tolerable
in our own eyes
but because our problem didn't begin
with work nor can work ever prove the
solution
our real goal is not as we think to be
an ideal employee or professional it is
to feel acceptable
but responsibility for a sense of
acceptance cannot be handed over to our
bosses or customers or a ceaselessly
demanding capitalist system
these will never let us rest easy
because it is in their nature without
any evil intent always to demand more
we need to shift our sense of where our
drive is coming from
we are not unnaturally interested in
working perfectly
we are laboring under an unusually
intense impression that we are dreadful
people
a problem for which working harder
cannot be the answer
we need to allow ourselves to imagine
that we deserve to be accepted from the
start and that it cannot forever be our
fault in our minds that we are not
it is not up to us to try to prove that
we have a right to exist
it is asking too much of ourselves to
have to experience a referendum on our
legitimacy every time we hand in a
report
every exam we have to pass every
customer we have to serve
working well is naturally an admirable
goal
but it becomes a symptom of mental
perturbation when it becomes the cover
for a secret aspiration to correct a
deficit of early love
we should welcome an ability to tolerate
periods of laziness
not because we are congenitally idle but
because it is a sign that we have learnt
to speak more kindly to ourselves and to
be appropriately angry with those who
could not at the outset accept us for
who we were without a surfeit of
trophies and prizes
follow the link on your screen now to
explore our range of books games and
gifts all designed to help you better
understand yourself